ten of which the doctor would wipe my
memory of this thought so there's more
obviously into the new series of Doctor
Who we've had our first episode it's
gotten rolling and something that I
already talked about which is the fact
that we know down the line in this
series we are getting John Simm back and
he is supposed to be appearing as the
master alongside Missy now I expressed
my kind of interest intrigue and
excitement at this because it is going
to be the first time we've had a multi
master story I in a show at anyway I
think they've done it at some of the
audios and possibly the novels but we've
never had it in the show before and that
really excites me something that struck
me a little bit odd though I guess I'm
not that surprised by it is I had a fair
number of people and I don't do and what
I talk about you know fan reactions I'm
learning Julie talked about what I see
in my own comment section I've gotten to
the point where I avoid a lot of the
message boards and whatnot I'm not
because I don't like those conversations
or whatnot I actually enjoy them but
when we're in to the season I just I
always fear about coming across spoilers
even if it's like I come across you know
fan theories that turn out to be correct
and it feels like a spoiler so I avoid
them for that reason so I don't know how
widespread this notion is but I have
seen it in my own comments that people
were throwing out the idea that bringing
Johnson back meant that Missy was going
to be revealed to be somebody other than
the master now I want to put flat out I
don't like that as an ocean I don't
believe it first of all but I really
don't like it as an ocean because well
for a number of reasons because that
just feels like that you know what that
feels like that feels like a super year
of comic book trope and you know just
the oh this character that you know it
was really this all times and it doesn't
feel like Doctor Who I mean multi-master
story is the kind of tiny by meanness
that doctor would allow us to experience
why would you check that in favor of a
much more cliched oh and here's the real
but here's the real
Marin you know that kind of junk so I
don't like that as a notion but I have I
thought suggested I've seen people say
like well maybe it's runny which I
really hope not because I don't like the
Ronnie of character but but that's all
on top of the fact that I don't like
this as a general notion but even though
I don't like it a general notion I had a
thought
and I had it the other day and I've had
a hard time shaking it and it has wormed
its way into my head and I I don't
believe this to be the case and I really
hope it isn't but I kind of want to put
it on record that it occurred to me so
just on the off awful chance that it
does end up being the case it's on
record that I called it and this was the
thought that occurred to me because
people were also trying to ascribe some
meaning like some extra meaning beyond
just you know sentimentality to the
picture of Susan that the doctor has in
his office in in the first episode we
got in the pilot and my brain went and
mashed those two together and thought oh
my god what if they reveal that Missy is
really Susan oh god I hope not
I like I said I hate this idea and I
hate that I had it and I hate that I'm
having a hard time shaking it loose
um I've got no evidence to back this up
it was just a thought that occurred to
me that for whatever reason just gave me
that sinking feeling that it's just it
maybe effect sinking feeling that makes
it hard to shake it was just what I did
was like oh that's something they could
do it probably would be sticky I might
have even forgotten about it by now but
it's it's just that Oh God oh and and
again I want to assess like I I don't
think that showing Susan is meant to
have extra poignancy or extra meaning in
the first place I think it's just sort
of tying back to his history I feel like
the show is embracing its longtime has
more lately I mean just showing that
that that cup with all the different
sonic screwdrivers including a ton that
you know predate the the modern era that
ok hello they have a second doctor sonic
screwdriver and there was basically just
a penlight so you know i it is my
thought in my hope that all they're
doing is just doing more connections by
soldiers some I even saw somebody
suggest in the comments that maybe means
we're going to see the first doctor
again I don't think that's true either
but at the same time while I have
enjoyed Moffitt's tenure and I actually
am a defender of most of what he's done
I know that sometimes he gets too clever
for his own good and sometimes he has
notions and ideas that are clever on
paper and in the pursuit of executing
them he undermines other stuff for me
that was a big part of why Clara didn't
work especially at the tail end again I
I know some people love car and that's
great if you do I'm not here to argue
with you but I'm saying that that level
of you know being too clever by half is
the kind of mentality that could lead
someone to think that Susan being Missy
was a good idea and it's not I don't
think the idea bringing back Susan is a
great idea in the first place but the
idea of you know here's this longtime
ally and they're back and now they're
evil like again that's it's that's just
so so it's so superhero comic book and
it's not it's not Doctor Who yeah I just
needed to share this thought because I
felt like it was going to eat away at me
if I didn't just kind of good um get it
out there and maybe now that I've talked
about it and hopefully he people will
debunk it in the comments my dreaded
fear is that people are going to flood
my comments with a bunch of evidence
backing this idea up fertility hope that
but but whatever your thoughts are even
if you think I'm right drop something
down the Commons and let's talk about it
don't forget to like subscribe check me
out on Twitter council of geese give a
listen to the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher until
next time this council is adjourned
[Applause]